in the batman selena kyle is trying to
keep a lid on the evidence of her affair
with the mayoral candidate belarus which
will later turn into
unending vengeance against the court of
owls when her lover is slain
she's working for falcone as like this
dad figure that she doesn't have
if i have to see a strip of pearls be
pulled
from martha's neck one more time and
dramatically scatter on the ground
like i've seen it
welcome back to new rockstars we're
sneaking around your home in the dark
cracking your safe trying to steal your
precious plot twists
brushing our teeth with your teeth
brushes because this is rogue theory the
podcast that brings you
the wildest nerdy hot takes on the
topics you can't stop arguing about
i'm tommy bechtold and with me to pitch
rogue theories today
are the boy genius of new rock stars mr
eric voss
hi thank you for having me here i had to
get my mom's permission to stay this
long though
oh god you're like that kid that's only
friends with adults and it's just really
awkward for everyone
it's just communicate with your wife she
needs you
in a weird way he's always right but
it's also very uncomfortable also
joining us today is our friend comedian
and writer jessica clements hello
jessica
hi i always i always feel so
uncomfortable because everyone has stuff
in the background other video but me
it's just a white wall
um i got new flowers that's great oh
look at those
i want to say for the record i have what
it appears to be a large thing of dish
soap
a three-quarter jug of olive oil and
some garlic peppers so
don't be don't be jealous uh i'm pretty
i have like single dad
getting ready for a weekend with his
kids cooking stuff going on that's
everyone's time
yes nice perfect and finally our good
friend the host with the most miss maude
garrett oh my
i don't have a [ __ ] in kitchen but i do
have i
use new rockstar colours look at that
how how very thoughtful of you we we
truly appreciate that
it's been very lonely before we get
started obviously we're all still
reeling over the sudden passing of
chadwick boseman so
this is the first time many of us have
been together since the news
broke uh eric you wanted to say some
brief words before we get started
uh yeah um look everyone you know
learning about
chadwick boseman's death was devastating
to all of us and
uh to me as well obviously as someone
who has
made a lot of videos analyzing his
wonderful work and the role he played in
this fictional universe that we all love
so much
um and it was really uh a big wake-up
call
about uh the very real struggle that he
was going through
the entire time we knew him for the most
part
i don't know about you guys but i would
say beneath this heartbreak i just feel
a gratitude that he spent his final
years with us showing us
what uh courage and heroism really look
like and um
not to you know start things off too
heavy but i think i just think i speak
for all of us when i say
you know um as nerds we get it we're all
curious about what marvel might try to
do next with this franchise
we will get to talking about it
eventually for now i just ask
everyone let's just please spend this
time remembering chadwick and talking
about the endless
other things that there are to talk
about that we're going to do in this
episode
and um jessica mott if you have anything
you want to weigh in on
for sure i think you summed up how i
feel
uh i've been crying for the last like
three days but i feel like
uh it's finally stopped because i'm just
more so happy that also
the children today like my nephew got to
witness it
and be there for it and now we still
have these movies to come in the future
and we can still look back at it
especially as like our black superhero
it was
um it's a big deal but it's also just
like
at least we still had it yeah and it's a
good time
yeah his um the symbolism that he
brought was so
impactful that you know he saw it
worldwide
um i i got to interview him twice
actually um
when i was in seoul for the black
panther premiere
um and there was some there was like you
could just tell there was like this
almost attachment um yeah but he was so
into it and everyone was so happy and
like
you could see that he was just like he
was a part of the marvel family and it
was such a big deal
um and i i look back to the interviews
that i've done
and i look back to um other interviews
and i'm wondering sort of like
how much of his responses and answers
was him just sort of like personally
reflecting in his situation
sure and that's what breaks my heart um
and i know that sort of like the
transformation that you have to make to
be a marvel hero
is not only a physical sort of like
like massive change and it would be so
exhausting
and like you know so hard on the body
but then not only to
get into shape for that role but then do
the global press tour
and how like that can affect the mind
and body as well
um and i i think that what i hope is
that
the legacy that he's left as well as
being
black panther is someone who just
knuckled down and got the job done yeah
and i think that that kind of work ethic
is so unique to him because i think so
many other people
would want to sort of like not keep it a
secret and just share that struggle and
that hardship
and i'm so i admire so much that it was
a battle that he didn't want to have
publicly
and he made how many movies in the four
years that he was diagnosed
five or six i think yep like that is
just spectacular so yeah i think that
that
that is something that was so yeah yeah
something that i want to cherish yes
well said
uh everybody and i'll just add that i
know it can feel
very silly sometimes to feel this
personal attachment and grief to someone
that you've never met
but these people are you know we do feel
like we know them
and we do feel a certain pride in the
performances that they give in a certain
amount of
emotional attachment to them and that's
why i'm grateful for the communities
that we have these nerd communities like
rockstars and everything else that
people can kind of come together and
and support each other and and make this
thing that stings and hurts and
is you know the grief can be hard to
pinpoint a definition for it
it doesn't make any sense and it feels
very unfair but i
am grateful for everybody who was able
to be supportive
to to myself who was feeling sad
selfishly and then to everyone else who
was feeling bad i hope you were able to
find some support
as well and is if there's even a
possible way to move on to another topic
uh we're gonna try we have to but um
thank you uh thank you everybody for for
weighing in on that uh the five bloods
on netflix
guys if you haven't seen the five bloods
yet it's really really amazing sparkly
does an amazing job with storytelling
the genre changes throughout
chadwick boson's really good in it too
excellent uh all right
let's move on to the batman trailer
one thing we haven't really discussed at
length here is catwoman uh we got our
first look at zoe kravitz is selena kyle
who matt reeves said is not yet catwoman
in the movie so
for some mysterious reason she's
revisiting the crime scene of a murder
victim
in the trailer so what is selena kyle's
agenda in the batman is she going to be
a friend or foe eric we'll start with
you
yeah i'll i'll start and uh we're it's
not like we're forgetting anything we've
mentioned before
it's obviously an abrupt uh segue that
we're making here but
this is the the why you clicked on this
video so we're just gonna dive into it
uh because if you've been following new
rockstars the past couple days
um i've been diving deep into this
theory that the court of owls
is really gonna be evolved with this
movie um and i i went to
uh some pretty wild takes on like how
they could be involved in the mystery
plot based on the um
like the various visual clues and the
owl sightings that i think are all over
the footage but we haven't really gotten
into how selena kyle fits into it
obviously she's gonna
play a pretty big role in this story in
the trailer we saw her a couple times
like uh
there was the part where she seems to be
sneaking back into the crime scene
which is the mayor's home we think
breaking into his safe it looks like
batman kind of confronts her they they
stare each other down
it's kind of like a moment of tension
it's like where is this going
uh there's also a shot of her on a
motorcycle which you know doesn't tell
us much but it does confirm that we saw
that uh cemetery set
video footage that depicted her with
batman or at least their stunt
drivers uh they're either riding next to
each other or chasing each other down
but building on this court of owl's idea
i've been talking about i think
selena kyle is someone the court has
screwed over in gotham
and my theory is that she had a secret
romantic
relationship with the mayoral candidate
bella rayal who was just defeated in the
last election based on inclusion in the
trailer
and the the newly elected mayor's don
mitchell jr
uh and i think the way that he won was
by threatening to use the knowledge of
rael's affair with selena kyle in order
to ruin her they blackmailed her
so now uh what ended up having happened
is rael just had to kind of like
either concede or drop out or take a
dive in the race
uh and her you know it kind of ruined
her chances
and that evidence is still hidden and
don mitchell jr's safe
and selena has to come back into the
crime scene destroy it before the pd
gets their hands on it and ruins what's
left of belarus career
so i think in this mystery we're going
to see selena and batman working
together to investigate the owl's
conspiracy in gotham but then
as real is set up as a replacement mayor
figure the court sees that as a threat
and they kill her off assuming the
public will see it as just another
high-profile riddler assassination
after the mayor the d.a the commissioner
but really it wasn't the riddler it was
the court
so in the batman selena kyle is trying
to keep a lid on the evidence of her
affair with the mayoral candidate
belarus which will later turn into
unending vengeance against the court of
owls when her lover is slain
and if uh the kicker of my court of
health's theory is to be true
that um batman has been the unwitting
talon executioner for the court of owls
this whole time
that could set up a finale final act an
angry duel between the batman and selena
kyle
in the third act of this film oh eric
the theory had it all
romance blackmail betrayal
redemption i love it uh i love it so
much i
i i'm interested in that being part of
the movie i have no choice but to award
you
for your theory um one sweet potato
i'm gonna give you one microwave
this is made by wegmans and it's food
you feel good about
so you get one sweet potato for that
i feel good about this oh well that's
that's what that's what the awards are
that's what the rogies are today
they're sweet potatoes guys because
we're turning our lives around
it's september it's time to get those
fall bodies i'm talking
latte bodies pumpkin pie bodies
halloween candy 50
off on november 1st
about the election bodies everything
it's time for fall let's put those
bathing suits away and let's bring out
the chunky sweaters
yes they all look like sweet potatoes
yes that's all
this this potato is goals this is body
goals
with the barcode on it at all that's
right
ten minutes in the microwave i'm sure
it's not bad for you that it's wrapped
in plastic
mod we move to you now mud what is your
theory
uh i don't like going after eric yeah
i'll say that
but from what i heard from him he was
uh kind of like predicting that selena
kyle would go
start good and then sort of turn bad
my focus on this is introducing selena
kyle
again and it's like what take are we
gonna have this time
the last iteration movie version of uh
catwoman we saw was anne hathaway
that was probably the more disappointing
part of that movie
you didn't really get an origin story
that you cared about
juno temple was far more entertaining
every time
they were in the same scene together and
you just didn't really care
um and then the previous iterations of
catwoman i never watched gotham
but then you know halle berry the amount
of razzies that that one scored
i feel like i'm so so so
excited for this iteration of um
selena kyle i love that zoe kravitz is
playing the role because she has a
feline-esque quality
yeah i think that they are going to do a
twofer for this one they are because we
know batman's origin story and if i have
to see a strip of pearls be pulled
from martha's neck one more time and
dramatically scatter on the ground
like i've seen it yes so i kind of
love that we are doing new origin
stories and i want to have something
super chewy um so for this one i
actually want her to be
bad i want her to be uh you know teaming
up with the riddler i want that scorn of
gotham
to be really kind of like prominent i
want her to
be jaded at the world i mean she her
origin story is that she is a cat
burglar like she steals [ __ ] so if she's
going to be
a thief things aren't looking great for
her it's not something that's not a life
that you
want it's a life that you have to have
given the circumstances
so i want that gritty raw take and then
you you know enter
the batman and it's uh cedric diggory
who's definitely more tom riddle in this
one
and just kind of see that they both have
this disgruntled kind of like
you know chip on their shoulder when it
comes to gotham and then they realize
that if they combine their forces then
maybe they can actually get through it
together
instead of becoming the antithesis of
that which is the spiral of the riddler
so i think
that you know and the penguin so you
kind of see
they're all kind of in the same
headspace but it's what you do
with that and the actions that you take
that can either get you above it or suck
you down into it and so i kind of want
to see
that pairing off um in the movie but i
do not have
like the microscopic you know
look on the trailer and using evidence
i'm just saying this is what i
want you're you're absorbing the content
as just a fan and not as our as not as
our super
uh super uh researcher i understand that
uh a very unhealthy perspective
i'm just happy to be a potato i'm going
to be a sweet potato
you you are certainly going to get at
least one sweet potato mod but let me
tell you what i
uh for me personally what i enjoy is
that
the bringing together of batman and and
selena kyle in your theory is not that
he has to represent some sort of bastion
of good and as a savior
to her like it usually is portrayed it's
like no batman will be her redemption
she'll like
she'll want to be good because of that
to earn batman's love or feel like
worthy in the eyes of batman in this one
it's just because they both are jaded
and like
people that have been screwed over by
the same system can find a common ground
that way
as well or not necessarily screwed over
but just burned by it
so i really like that and for that you
do get one uh sweet potato and
you're also getting this is crazy i
can't believe that i'm giving this away
this is a uh necklace full of frozen
jewelry frozen the disney movie jewelry
that my niece made
each of these precious gems and you're
just gonna let it go
i know your theory was that good
your theory brought together the best of
both sweet potatoes
and uh frozen frozen gems uh
all right uh two great theories so far
jessica what do you got for us
oh gosh i love following mod
but i will do this okay so
i agree with both of the other people um
watching the batman and then watching
matt reeves talk about the batman i
really held on to the fact that uh matt
reeves was like
i'm taking a little bit from batman like
i'm taking what we all know but
ultimately it's not the same like it's
gonna be a little bit too different
it's also like starting at the beginning
of the batman
like it's gonna i feel like we're gonna
we see all this really hard
edgy um like batman but i feel like he's
also clumsy
he's gonna be doing things very sloppily
especially when he beat up that like
gangster and was just
letting out his aggression it was just
so violent that it was like okay he
doesn't know what he's doing yet he's
still learning
so i think the same is to be said about
zoe kravitz as catwoman
um i think absolutely she's just gonna
be like selena trying to find her way in
her steps but i think she's finding her
steps because she's related
to falcone so i love the idea
of i love the theory and i love the
issues where they were like
oh it's his illegitimate like long time
daughter i love the idea of that and i
would love that storyline to come into
matt reeves comic books
because then you can do so much in that
world and i think what's gonna happen
ultimately is she's gonna be like
chaotic good but also chaotic neutral
because it's still catwoman she's gonna
look out for herself ultimately
but i think she's working for falcone as
like
this dad figure that she doesn't have
because she's an orphan she doesn't have
anyone
so i think she's willing to like listen
to what he has to say and do what he
wants her to do
which i think in turn fell cohn
i stole this from gotham the tv show uh
falcone said
that you can't have like organized crime
without law and order
so i think falcone is going to be in
there working with the politicians
making all of this organized crime and
the riddler is like i've had enough of
this [ __ ] because the riddler is like
ultimately
everyone has to be accountable for what
they do so i think
the riddler is going to be like bringing
up all this stuff from the dirt that no
one really knows and falcone's trying to
catch up and get all that evidence
while he's killing the politicians that
are ultimately using like being the
puppets
so i think phil combs having zoe kravitz
go places
stealing from the safe yeah stealing
evidence for falcone so
nothing comes back to them i also think
cobble paul is also working with lcon
just like erasing any trails i think
ultimately at the end of the movie
obviously she'll be like i don't need
you
because it's catwoman she's the greatest
and so i think that's when she becomes
chaotic neutral when she's only thinking
about herself
but at the beginning of the movie we're
going to see that chaotic good because
you know you still need a storyline
you still need a climax you still need
other writing things that i don't know
what other writing i don't know the
lingo before
yeah you can't just go plateau the
entire time
i would love a movie that's just
straight violence and just
and just robber pants and beating up
people but yeah
you can't do that breaking noses it'd be
tough just the raid
just the raid with batman yeah oh i
would love it
so i think i think she is going to be a
foe but also
ultimately they're going to have the
shared goal of trying to just figure out
who's at the end of this who's doing all
this but i think zoe kravitz
catwoman is obviously smarter than
batman sorry
fans of batman but i think she's going
to be smarter than batman and be like
you don't understand the big picture
because you're also part of the problem
he's got time yes he's like a horse with
blinders he's like no
i'm defeating the bad guys but there's a
bigger world and batman is a small man
he's a small clumsy man he's
accidentally
breaking people's jaws and slipping on
martha's pearls
yes and slipping on them so i think
that's how
we're gonna see zoe kravitz be playing
catwoman as still like
a badass beach i like it uh
i i i enjoy the the version of catwoman
that that personally i think is most
interesting is the one that is
willing to do good things and be helpful
and prevent
uh you know unnecessary or unjust things
from happening
but is ultimately very opportunistic and
is like you know
still going to look out for herself
number one i think that is the most
interesting
and i love your theory uh you know and i
hope that it comes to fruition that
that we do get find some more connective
tissue between like felconi
and selena kyle or our characters like i
mean it's just interesting it's
something that we haven't really seen
played out on screen
before but and whether it's a comic book
story line or not
regardless but uh yeah so i think that's
uh i love that theory as well three for
three gang i'm gonna award you
uh two things a sweet potato for
yourself there's all three of your sweet
potatoes today
and then in a very self-serving award
i'm gonna award you uh
the boys omnibus volume two just so this
is a perfect way to segue to remind
people to watch uh eric and myself
uh on the boys underground on this
channel uh so a little self-promotion
uh mixed in like the catwoman a little
self-serving
in with my justice so there you go i'm
proud of you tommy
thank you so much i i'm proud of of all
all three of you and myself uh before we
bring up
we still have some great uh theories to
come up but first we need to do a little
business here
and i want to talk to you guys about a
company that
as you know i'm very passionate about
expressvpn you might know
that expressvpn protects your piracy
your piracy
yeah yeah well it definitely protects
your piracy if you uh are into that
but uh it also protects your privacy and
security online
uh but you might not know that it can
also help you unlock movies and shows
that are only available in other
countries
have you been dying to watch the
portuguese version of the office as much
as i have
yo soy jim ah that's probably not
portuguese q
the portuguese fans to hammer me
witness me portuguese fans for i am a
terrible person star trek discovery is
on netflix uk
and rick and morty is on netflix france
we
we we but neither of them are on u.s
netflix
what the [ __ ] as i say an american to
watch content not normally available to
you just fire up the expressvpn app
fire it on up in the hopper change your
location hit connect
up refresh netflix hulu or some other
streaming service
and bang you're off and running and it
feels so bad to watch that good content
because you're not really in the
netherlands you're right here in
rochester new york
watching rick and morty laughing along
at star trek discovery some of the
funnier moments i recently watched
some fresh prince of bel-air episodes on
netflix australia
just because i could it was crazy why
did i watch it i don't know
good day will ah anyway express sorry
mod
leave best bus vps expressvpn hides your
ip address
and lets you control where you want
sites to think that you're located it's
like where in the world is carbon san
diego except for in my case it's a thick
neck bearded man
uh again hiding out in his dad's cottage
till coveted you can choose from almost
100 different countries isn't that fun
there are hundreds of vpns out there
expressvpn is ridiculously fast
there's never any buffering or lag and
you can stream in hd without problems i
like that no buffering no lag no parents
walking in on you in embarrassing
moments because you can time out the
videos that you watch
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices phones
media consoles smart tvs and more try
beaming into a pager i don't know you
crazy kids you got spare time right now
so you can watch what you want on a
personal device or on the big screen
wherever you are if you use my link
right now at expressvpn.comrogue you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
for free that's e
s e-x-p-r-e-s vpn dot com slash rogue
and i'm stealing that karaoke mic away
from you because i want to thank some
other friends who helped us make this
episode
helix sleep there are more reasons than
ever why you might not be getting great
sleep right now but
your mattress should not be one of those
reasons helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses
made in america and shipped straight to
your door with free no contact delivery
free returns
and a 100 night sleep trial to choose a
mattress helix made
a two-minute quiz that matches your body
type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you they say
there's
one person out there for each of us well
that's not true but there is one
mattress out there for everyone
it's made in a factory and it's shipped
to you and it's really the only lover
you need
it's helix
and in my case my mattress lover is i
believe it is the helix
dusk lukes what's great about this
mattress i'm like
i i roll around a lot when i sleep i'm
constantly like sleeping on my back and
then my girlfriend hits me and she's
like
you are snoring and uh it's causing this
problem
uh but helix takes care of all that it
made a mattress that like accounts for
that kind of awful sleeper helix was
awarded number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
wired magazine and apartment therapy
all you gotta do is go to helix
sleep.com rogue theory take their two
minutes leap quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you're gonna love it helixes operate up
to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleep.com
rogue theory that's helix hdl ix sleep
dot com slash rogue theory for up to 200
off and when you wake up from your
wonderful night of sleep what are you
going to want to eat you're going to
want to eat some cereal but
unlike when you're a kid you can't just
keep shoveling in that sugary
cereal because you won't be alive much
longer but i love breakfast cereal i
still want the flavor and the experience
of breakfast cereal without the
destruction it does to my body well
lucky for me there's magic spoon cereal
that i've been munching on all episode
uh it has zero grams of sugar 11 grams
of protein only
three net grams of carb in each serving
it's uh these are they're fruity uh loop
shaped ones um but they're better for
you it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free gmo free would i be
eating it
if i didn't love it actually i do really
like it sometimes we have to consume
things on camera
and you have to really hide the winds
because i don't like it
this i actually do like i if i did make
such an annoying crunch throughout the
episode
into the microphone i would be eating it
throughout the broadcast there are four
fruity flavors to choose from
cocoa fruity frosted blueberry i like
frosted a lot
um but i i think i'm uh enjoying these
this is my new favorite
the the fruit fruity flavor
it tastes amazing and it's become my
go-to cartoon watching breakfast
cereal because um it there's a lot of
cartoons being watched here
uh just go to magicspoon.com rockstars
to grab a variety pack
and try it today and be sure to use our
promo code rockstars at checkout to get
free shipping
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it is backed with a 100 percent
happiness guarantee anything else gonna
guarantee your happiness
no but this delivers so if you don't
like it for any reason they'll refund
your money no questions asked but
trust me you're gonna like it it's
magicspoon.com rockstars and usual code
rockstars for free shipping
all right thank you eric and i just want
to go back to the helix thing you don't
roll around that much in your sleep
trust me i'm watching every night
anyway let's talk black adam in
the black atom panel at dc fandome
fandom
dwayne johnson called out the justice
league superheroes and teased that we
might see a rumble
between him and superman so my question
for you guys which surprise dc matchup
do you think we could see
in the black adam film jessica we'll
start with you i think
that we would see i think we'd see him
go against wonder woman especially
because he brought it up
um he brought up his like two favorites
or he didn't say favorites
but he brought up two people that he was
like very interested in seeing
um in his in the movies and it was
wonder woman and superman
and we're all expecting like a superman
and black adam fight but i want to see a
wonder woman and blackoutify especially
with her like
electricity power i like that uh a
wonderful theory about wonder woman for
that i award you
uh this sweet potato and also this sweet
potato
i think that's all the same potatoes no
no there's
this one and then there's this one and
then there's this one and then there's
this one
and there's a whole baker's dozen of
sweet potatoes i promise but
a bigger one in a
[Laughter]
thank video thank god we had the
quarantine so i can do my
potato trick and trust me i have a lo i
have a whole routine with potatoes but
it's
as long as you don't say that i say
potato because i don't say potato
you don't you know she just did you say
tomato
that's where i draw the line um
well first of all i think we need a
spin-off which is
just um you know the justice league
needs therapy because already we've had
batman v superman and now it's going to
be black out and be someone
it's like why all the hostility and
discourse
like just hug it out that being said
there's two that i am hoping the first
one is
uh jason mamoa obviously aquaman um
we've seen in his origin story he's got
a bit of a tempe temper
and you know he's also the biggest and
so the only thing that's going to get
him more razzed up is someone even
bigger so i think that they're going to
have
a fisty cuffs over that i want it to be
i want him to be the flash i want to see
dwayne the rock johnson
punch ezra miller
that would make and also in the movie
but not just
my fantasy fight club yes
um that would be great so
i couldn't tell you why it's happening
just that it could happen yeah
i think for your theory first of all
when you said that jason momoa was the
biggest ben affleck immediately started
chugging weight gainer 3000
i am the thickest batman ever and i did
that for a reason
uh have you seen his dragon phoenixy
tattoo that covers
yes i got one no i'm just kidding i
don't
show us your back all right
for that theory i give you this sweet
potato and
this sweet potato two potatoes for you
and no potatoes eric bring us home
um i'm my theory is similar to
mod's second part of hers i want to see
uh black adam get in a fight with jared
leto joker
um who cannot die every time you think
he's dead
he just keeps showing back up again i
have had that nightmare before
you know where like you try to this is
too much information
no this is why you need a helix mattress
when you try to kill someone or like you
know
in them or fight them and they keep
laughing at you and that even though
their face is broken
and they're all bruised and bloody they
keep laughing
that's what i'm picturing with this i in
my dreams whenever i punch someone it
doesn't hurt them at all which has
translated to me being very scared to
fight in real life because i'll have
these dreams where i have to
fight my way out and i'm throwing
punches and they all just go like yeah
they land very softly
yeah it's too far screaming yes yeah i
want jared leto
uh like every time the black adam thinks
he's done
you hear a hunk up around the corner
he's like god damn it and then at one
point like
like his tattoos jump off his body onto
jared leto's tattoos
and he has to like fight all the dumb
like hahahas
and uh broken and and like they're
starting to smother him
and it just gets insane and then and
then so it's just like him
smashing his skull again this is getting
too violent i'm sorry
wiping the smile off his face i like it
i i i like your theory eric if for the
only reason of
dwayne johnson having to suffer jared
leto's weird like gift-giving
that he does when he plays the joker
like [ __ ] thumb
why like why did you send me a thumb and
then him just taking it out on jared
little
dead pig wasn't it yeah yeah yeah
semen filled condoms like awesome
totally normal
and i'll tell you what if you saw the
movie it really paid off
uh anyway for that i will give you
uh this potato and oh
that's it no just kidding this potato oh
that's right
this potato how many potatoes
how many potatoes do you think that
keeps giving i'm giving you three
potatoes for your three because i
just like the idea of an unkillable
joker uh
oh my god that's not fair this scorpion
king is gonna be so good
yes i truly i cannot wait i don't mean
that sarcastically
i am excited for this movie and honestly
i hope all three of your theories come
true
now it's time for what i like to call
the most entertaining four and a half
minutes on
the internet it's rogue questions
everyone these questions come out of
nowhere
these questions could be questions that
have been hiding in the shadows lurking
on airplanes everyone dressed in black
on the plane
just kidding that won't be topical by
the time this airs so
as part of dc's upcoming batman day
they've announced a partnership
with the map app waze let me ask you
guys what comics character
would you least want to get driving
directions from i would say vision
uh only because i don't want to be in
the same car as vision
but like you could imagine jarvis's
voice being like a waze app
option um and i and i don't
i don't want to hang out with vision i
don't want to be in a car with him
he'd be really annoying and then he
doesn't like vision
i'm not a fan i'm not a fan of him and
then he'd he'd accidentally shoot rhodey
and then i'd be the worst day of our
lives
also if fission was in charge of
navigating he'd just be telling you to
drive through things because he does not
respond
thank you sir thank you sir a sweet
potato for tommy
drive through the embankment drive
through the embankment over to the other
side of the wall without
survive through your next left turn
don't
mind the gap drive
all right who else who else who else
bain guys are you kidding me
if i'm driving a car and i have to
crashing this car with no survivors
[Music]
there are no survivors um i have like
i couldn't choose between the two
because i was thinking when you said
comics i was thinking outside the box
so i was like oh the cobra commander
number one
because i don't need that screeching
done
my second was uh i said doctor strange
because you see the guy that says go
west and i wouldn't know what direction
all right uh those are very good but in
the end i do think bane's confusing
muffled voice is the winner of this one
so mata give you one potato
for that next question you can make it
to potato salad now
a sweet potato salad which i don't know
if there's a thing that anyone would
want
uh i'll eat it question two swarovski
swarovski the crystal bakers announced a
new etched crystal
baby yoda figurine for sale for 170
so i asked the three of you how could
you make a baby yoda figurine or a toy
that is even less huggable than that i
would want to
make you know i've never been to a gun
range but the
the thing the shooting target practices
why isn't there a baby
to one of those after the episode where
the storm troopers were trying to
shoot the can and they were trying to
yeah
like what are those oh my god yes
i uh i think you do yeah unlock
yeah you have to get on that because
someone's going to take that idea and
make too much money off it that's good
that's to be a mod original
for sure it's just too cute
you want to like make him out of hot
plates
i feel like you can't hug a hot plate so
like to get
really hot no going to play with a hot
plate baby no
no yoga that's just common sense baby yo
yeah watch out baby yoga
please it's real name is the child's
pose
baby yoga all right potato for me
ah it's not good it's going plastic eric
what do you got
um i don't know we might have to cut
this but
maybe the only way you can make baby
yoda less huggable is like revealing
that
he has committed various cases of sexual
misconduct
you might have said that look at the
children never
hug that child well we do think that
baby yoda might be like 52 years old
right something along that's right
that's right he looks cute but that's
how they get you these these 50 year
olds who look like little babies
uh all the people that have been
committing them yeah
i i like to think of myself as a strict
interpreter of these questions so i'm
giving jessica the potato
based on the fact that she's the only
one who answered she answered the
question she did actually
i i will take that pity potato the
actual potato
pity potatoes for everybody the actual
question
uh the answer of course would be a
cactus uh a cactus
it's okay where my mind should have gone
finally the most important question
dictionary.com just added the dwayne the
rock johnson catchphrase jabroni
to its list of words could you please
use the word jabroni in a sentence to
describe
something that has happened uh in the
last 24 hours to you
um well as we all know uh dwayne the
rock johnson
is an avid fan of my little ponies
making him a brony
and so when they connect and talk
and he talks to his fellow oh gibroni
i hate this question i'll tell you what
you rhymed and that's the easy pathway
to my heart uh anyway
jabroni it sounds like a pasta now it
sounds like a pasta
rag spaghetti
um
uh i would say um in the past 24 hours
this sounds not real but it actually
happened to me um
jabroni a noun um a person
or object that hits you on a bicycle
while you're riding your bicycle at 6 30
in the morning
um and the sentence would be uh i was
riding my bike
and a jabroni flew into my helmet no
i'm not a
i'll be honest i'm sad that it lived uh
just kidding sorry guys don't at me
eric what do you have to say okay um
jabroni
noun a muscle-bound
sleep demon that when one sleeps
on a helix mattress sleeps so well
he feels like he's at rock bottom yeja
brody
it doesn't matter what kind of matches
you sleep on cause can you
smell what helix made your sleep
youtube brody wow
it must be a great match what what you
did it's a pretty good one uh
what you did was wonderful but
unfortunately the tie-in for
a product disqualifies you yeah it's
pretty silly
disgusting of capitalism mod because you
combined rhyming
pasta and dwayne the rock johnson my
three favorite things my holy trinity if
you will i award you
this potato and
all right mod let's tell her what she's
won mod is winner of rogue theory today
you get to get
one wish that can be achieved by either
our editing team or the people sitting
in the zoo meeting in front of you
do you have a wish planned for today i
want to hear everyone do their best
australian accent oh perfect
all right everyone do their best
australian accent
boy your c word all right
perfect that's so accurate yes
let's see i'm vengeance i'm the night
i'm batman
i'll bring us home with she was the best
girl i ever had hi
everyone i'm keith urban and that
sounded like a country trying but as a
matter of fact i'm australian
uh perfect wow guys
i don't have any friends left
oh boy unfortunately we had to end this
on such a pathetic note
that is rogue theory thank you all for
joining us congratulations to mod but
also congratulations
to jessica and eric uh thank you to our
guests eric voss
i love you mod garrett follow them at
the uh
handles that i'm sure we are now
displaying don't forget to subscribe
to the rogue theory podcast feed and
stay tuned to the youtube channel for
this
and other shows follow us on twitter at
new rockstar follow me
to freedom uh all right thanks everybody
have a great night
bye oh boy
[Music]
you